Hi. I'm Mike, and I wanna talk
about how a lot
of us are using
taxonomies to connect data.
A very special kind
of data, knowledge,
usually based on language,
not on numbers.
We still have a lot left to do
if we're going to
build the foundations
for a new generation
of semantic
technologies and artificial
intelligence. I
haven't presented
to a connected data
world audience
before, so let me
introduce myself.
I have an unusual background,
including
professional tours of
duty as a scholar,
laboratory scientist,
management consultant,
and technologist,
which seems to baffle many of
my colleagues.
At this point,
I've been working
in AI for more than
twenty years.
And now I've been
tech lead for
knowledge graphs
at LinkedIn for
several years.
Tech lead simply
means that when no one else
knows what to do
some how to do
something, you have to come up
with a solution as
soon as possible.
I wouldn't have
any other role.
And there's a theme
to my varied career.
It's all about
connecting language
and knowledge in wonderful and
scalable ways.
So it's fitting that I work in
cognitive computing
at the intersection
of human expertise and machine
intelligence. Drawing on this
very background,
I have extensive experience
looking at how both humans and
machines perform
the same language
and knowledge related tasks.
The title of this talk
alludes to Perl,
the programming language that
was often referred
to as the duct
tape of the Internet.
Duct tape is good because it's
flexible and easy to use,
but it tends to hide problems
rather than fix them,
and it's difficult
to troubleshoot
and extend.
I'm seeing lots
of teams trying
to connect data
using taxonomies
as duct tape with predictably
unreliable results.
And this is
particularly important
because I see
a dramatic increase
in work on
developing taxonomies
at leading companies.
If, as the saying goes,
experience is a fancy name for
all the errors that
you've committed,
then I have a lot
of experience
to talk about.
I'd like to tell
you about some of
my misadventures
in knowledge organization.
We're all familiar with simple
taxonomies. I see
more and more
investment in developing them
for industrial purposes with
each passing year.
I see more publications on
taxonomies and
more job postings
for taxonomists.
I hear of more new teams and
field more and more questions
about how to start
building a taxonomy
team. But are
taxonomies the best
use of our time?
Most of us have heard about
taxonomies since biology class
in sixth grade.
We assume that
they're important
and useful even when we don't
have a very clear idea of what
the details are.
So what I frequently
see is that
teams who face challenges of
knowledge organization turn to
taxonomies as their
first choice.
Unfortunately, taxonomies are
rather murky territory.
There's no explicit definition
of them that's
easily findable.
There are no best practices.
There are few
experienced people
who know how to build them.
There are no
reliable evaluation
methods and
essentially no notion
of done.
And since there's almost no
reliable
reliable documentation
to fall back on,
we essentially have to rely on
what we remember from biology
class and hope for the best.
But that's not a lot
to work with.
So this is a classic duct tape
situation. It's
almost guaranteed
to produce flawed
results at a high
cost. But we forge ahead.
We build a tech a taxonomy.
And it seems like
every time we
build a taxonomy,
the same thing happens.
We put a lot of effort into
making it correct
and coherent,
then get sign off from
key stakeholders.
Things look like
they're going well.
It's almost time to move on to
the next project,
and there are so many of them
as more people
start to understand
the importance of our work.
But when we try to get buy in
from product partners,
dozens of questions
come up crop
up from the CEO sometimes all
the way on down the line.
There are a wide
range of questions,
and all of them
seem to be theme
and variations on this doesn't
meet our requirements.
What did we do wrong?
Oh, and if this
hasn't happened
to you yet, it
will. Believe me.
And when the CEO and product
leaders are breathing
down your neck,
it gets uncomfortable.
So this situation
really wreaks
havoc with our
schedule and with
our morale too because we have
so much explaining
and rework to do.
So part of my job
is to understand
what's going on and
to fix it somehow.
This is the classic
tech lead question,
why did this happen?
And I find it very valuable to
listen first and
very carefully,
to spend time
understanding how
stakeholders think
about our very nerdy,
very technical issues.
The stakeholders make it sound
like a taxonomy
really does not
meet our needs and
that we screwed up.
So let's look at the kinds of
issues that stakeholders raise
when faced with a taxonomy.
I don't have to tell you that
product managers ask
lots of questions.
They're usually worried that
rolling out a new
taxonomy will
wreck their products,
even if right now
they're using
very messy data.
Their questions often focus on
other related entities,
like dog houses
and dog shampoo
and veterinarians
and pedigrees.
They sense pretty quickly that
taxonomies create issues of
coverage of the domain.
You probably don't
want to answer
that this kind of information
doesn't fit into taxonomy,
even though that's true.
You might mention, though,
that there were
parts of the product
requirements that
weren't so clear.
The taxonomists
slaving away in
the trenches also have lots of
questions. Their
questions often
focus on the many,
many exceptions and edge cases
of what's correct.
They ask, where should I put
mixed breed dogs
or service dogs
of unknown breeds or hunting
dogs that are also pets.
They sense pretty quickly that
taxonomies create issues or
accuracy of the domain.
Of course, managers
of all stripes
have lots and lots
of questions.
And their questions
often focus on more,
better, faster, and cheaper.
They'll ask, how will you make
the process faster?
How you expand to
new domains faster?
How can we evaluate
the workers better?
They sense pretty quickly that
taxonomies create
issues of scalability.
And the users, of course,
also have lots of questions.
Their questions
office focus on,
why don't you say
it like I do?
They ask things like,
why do you call
them service dogs?
I call them support dogs.
And hunting dog,
don't you actually
mean a sent out?
And we can see pretty quickly
that taxonomies create issues
of communication of
the domain as well.
Taxonomies rely crucially on
the category labels
to communicate
different concepts,
but different people
use different
terms.
Given these many
limitations, at best,
a taxonomy might be a patch or
a short term workaround.
So far, we've learned
a few things.
Taxonomies create
a range of big
problems: Problems
of coverage,
problems of accuracy,
problems of scalability,
and problems of
communication.
But why? Why aren't taxonomies
working for us?
If we don't understand why,
we'll just keep
repeating our mistakes.
But do we need to fix
our communication,
or do we need to
fix taxonomies
themselves? Stakeholders look
at taxonomies as a black box.
We need to open up
this black box.
Let's go back to the beginning
for a second. Is
this unexamined
assumption a good one?
It's starting to
look like it's not,
and I can see two
possible reasons.
Either we're not building them
correctly, or we're building
the wrong things.
So we need to
understand taxonomies
better to see how
well they will
work for us.
Taxonomies are
tools for knowledge
organization. Okay.
My key question
today though is
how good are these tools for
connecting data?
It's surprisingly difficult to
find definitions of taxonomy
with clear explicit criteria.
I really had to
dig to go beyond
a system of
classification used
in biology, blah blah blah.
It turns out that
taxonomies are
built with a very
specific formal
framework that is based on set
theory and formal logic.
There's a system
of interrelated
conventions like those listed
here that essentially define
what a taxonomy is.
There are many
issues with these
assumptions, but
for the moment,
let's focus on some
of the practical
consequences of assuming that
they are useful.
Taxonomies assume that there's
only one kind of item
in each taxonomy,
for example,
a taxonomy of dogs.
This is just to say
that taxonomies
are focused. We
don't find a single
taxonomy that includes
dogs, houses,
and shampoos. And
this makes sense.
Taxonomies represent
degrees of
similarity, and dogs, houses,
and shampoo are not similar.
But taxonomies
make it hard for
us to describe other
related entities,
like dog houses, dog shows,
and veterinarians.
And taxonomies
usually don't go
beyond entities to
describe events,
processes, states,
contingencies,
or other things.
I keep hearing
that we can simply
use related terms to include
other entities.
But related terms,
as you see here,
are subjective
and ill defined.
The unclear semantics makes it
very hard to guide
and validate
consistent choices
of related terms.
Taxonomies also assume that
categories are
essentially labeled
sets of items. For example,
these are the items
in category X.
And labels are
very often taken
to be enough to
describe the semantics
of a category.
But labeled sets are the bane
of our existence.
When categories
have labels and
no explicit semantics,
it's nearly impossible
to annotate
and validate their
members consistently.
This is very,
very common in my
experience. Annotators most
often work from labels without
explicit definitions or well
documented guidelines.
And that means that we can't
describe exactly
why an item is
in a category, or even what it
means to be in a category,
or how to validate
the placement
of an item in a category.
Taxonomies also assume that
items are in one and
only one category.
Like, final is
an example of a setter
and is not in any
other category.
This is the most frequent
assumption for
standard taxonomies.
Of course, permitting multiple
categories or
parents is an option
for extending our taxonomies.
But what do we do then with
double counting?
If each item can appear in
multiple categories,
then their
occurrences will sum
to more than one
hundred percent.
And one key use
case for taxonomies
is aggregating data
for insights.
Besides, multiple
parents won't
help with cases like
we don't know,
where there's not
enough information,
or there's a data error.
If item x is in category y has
to be entirely true
or entirely false,
then a statement like nursery
manager is in
category healthcare
jobs will force
us to incorrectly
classify professionals who
cultivate trees and shrubs as
health care workers.
In part because of
this assumption,
we still don't
have good methods
for evaluating items that are
partially correct or
totally irrelevant.
Taxonomies also
assume that only
one kind of relation exists
between items and categories.
In parallel to set theory,
an item is a member
of a category.
Like Fido is
an example of setter.
But that means that we can't
describe things like Fido is
bigger than poodles or similar
to terriers.
The usual conventions
of taxonomies
make it very difficult for us
to describe other kinds of
relations between
items and categories.
The same thing holds
for the relation
between one category
and another.
In parallel to set theory,
a category can be a subset of
another category,
like setters or a kind
of hunting dogs.
But cats aren't
a subset of dogs,
so we can't describe
any relations
between them.
The usual conventions
of taxonomies
make it very difficult for us
to describe other kinds of
relations between categories
like the ones listed here.
We've learned a few
more things.
So now we can see
why taxonomies
create a range of
big problems.
Assumptions about items and
relations lead to
problems of coverage.
Assumptions about categories
lead to problems
of communication
and of accuracy.
And assumptions
about the nature
of true and false
lead to problems
of accuracy and scalability.
Taxonomies create
problems because
they're simply not the right
tool for many of
our use cases.
And we've seen
why the field is
moving away from taxonomies to
ontologies and
knowledge graphs,
because ontologies
and knowledge
graphs impose
fewer restrictions
on the kinds of
knowledge we can
represent.
So my first lesson from all of
this is that taxonomies are in
fact a kludge, not a fix.
We're barking up
the wrong tree.
And my second lesson is that
build a taxonomy
doesn't always
mean that we should
build an actual
taxonomy because stakeholders
often aren't clear
on what a taxonomy
is or on the other
options that we have.
So we need to
understand taxonomies
better to guide
other stakeholders
better.
The good news is
that we can do
much better than taxonomies.
In fact, we have to
do much better.
We're building the foundations
for a new generation
of semantic
technologies and artificial
intelligence. We have
to get it right.
I'd like to backtrack
for a minute
and ask, why did we care about
taxonomies in
the first place?
What are we trying to get done
with them?
For a long time,
we've thought in
stark black and
white terms:
machine only versus human only
intelligence. We assume that
there are only two
options available.
Indeed, many AI practitioners
assume that autonomous machine
only AI is the best
goal for the field.
And human only
intelligence does
not scale in the ways that we
need it to.
In addition, today's standard
practice is to keep human
expertise separate
and leverage
it mostly for better AI,
and only sometimes to leverage
AI for better
human expertise.
But what about
the Fifty Shades
of Grey in the middle?
Saying that
machine intelligence
and human expertise
are the only
two options is fake news.
It's a false dichotomy because
there are many
unexplored shades
of mixed intelligence
in the middle.
We can arrange the options on
a scale from least machine
participation to most.
And from the beginning
of the field,
there have been
heated discussions
about whether the overarching
goal should be
autonomous machine
intelligence or
augmentation of
human intelligence And
now the discussion
has progressed
to talk about hybrid
intelligence,
where humans and machines work
as one integrated system.
So be sure to watch Frank von
Harmelin's keynote
about hybrid
intelligence, and let me wet
your appetite with a taste of
what he'll be talking about.
Hybrid intelligence refers to
systems where humans
contribute insight,
creativity, strategy,
and qualitative
evaluation that
machines lack. And machines
contribute speed,
thoroughness,
strength, comprehensiveness,
coordination, and reliability
that humans lack.
That is, we're
looking for systems
where we get the best of both
human expertise and machine
intelligence.
And what is hybrid
intelligence like?
It's like the situations where
humans and machines
do the same
task at the same time.
Humans and machines
interact in
real time. This is like
collaborative AI.
And for that, we need
explainable AI.
Machines learn from humans and
humans from machines,
which I call
reciprocal learning.
And this isn't
science fiction.
There are cutting
edge products
with hybrid
intelligence already
available on the market,
like adaptive machine
translation,
where the machine adapts
translations and style in real
time according
to human input,
and humans can learn
from the machine's
consensual
translations as well.
We strategically
choose the right
intelligence for
the right parts
of each problem to get
the best of both.
We trust the machine based on
understanding and
monitoring its
reasoning. Of course,
we need lots more research to
understand better what humans
do best and what machines do
best in these kinds of hybrid
intelligence settings,
and this will allow us to
partition and assign tasks to
achieve the best of both.
But it's already
clear that for
hybrid intelligence,
we'll need knowledge
in different
forms that both humans and
machines can use.
So be sure to watch
Gadi Singer's
keynote here about
levels of knowledge.
And again, let me whet your
appetite with a taste of what
he'll be talking about.
Goddy makes a very
significant point.
We don't need to
choose between
deep learning
models and symbolic
knowledge. We'll
need both and more!
Neurosymbolic
systems are starting
to explore this space.
Gotti talks about three levels
of knowledge, instantaneous
knowledge that's directly
available in an AI system in
the form of embeddings
or models,
standby knowledge
which requires
little extra processing and is
slower than instantaneous
knowledge.
But it's applicable
to more situations,
and it's probably formulated
into some standardized
representation.
Unless he talks
about retrieved
external knowledge,
which is external information
that is probably temporarily
relevant and often shows up in
the form of free text.
So let's leverage the concepts
of hybrid intelligence
and levels
of knowledge to
articulate more
precise goals for knowledge
organization and
connected data.
This way, we'll have a clearer
direction to lead us beyond
building simplistic
taxonomies.
Again, we've learned
a few more things.
Now we can see why we need to
move beyond taxonomies
and duct tape.
We need different
forms of knowledge,
not just taxonomies
or just models.
We need to work toward hybrid
intelligence, not just machine
intelligence. And we need to
enable human
machine communication
with clear semantics.
For hybrid intelligence,
we'll need Godly's standby
knowledge in place
of simplistic
taxonomies. And how
can we get there?
Let's make a to do list.
First, we need to understand
what are more
reliable building
blocks than taxonomies.
And the first of those is what
I call concept catalogs,
List of distinct important
concepts in
different domains,
along with different ways of
expressing them,
as you can see in
the table below.
They have many advantages over
taxonomies, and
possibly the biggest
advantage is that they reduce
subsequent processing
and human review,
often by a factor
of fifty or more,
because there are often fifty
or more different
textual forms
for the same concept.
So with that,
they dramatically
increase recall for search,
instances for
machine learning,
and reliability
of insights and
analytics. Concept
catalogs are
useful whether you
build taxonomies
or not, and I
suspect that they
account for most
of the ROI that
we get from building
taxonomies.
We're all newbies,
but biologists
have been working
with taxonomies for more than
three hundred years.
They've learned a few useful
things from all of
that experience.
One is building what they call
identification keys,
which are essentially feature
arrays that
constitute definitions
of species. They are a list of
distinct important
features and
values for each species.
We need something very similar
for concepts generally,
not just for species.
This is very
similar to what AI
engineers call
a feature space.
There are lots
of advantages of
this over taxonomies.
Categories are
output, not input.
We can combine the features in
different ways to
make different
kinds of categories,
it's not restricted
to one entity type,
and the features are explicit
and accessible to algorithms
rather than hidden
inside human
definitions.
Another building block that we
have to talk about is another
kind of feature space,
one that I haven't
seen deployed
in recent work.
But feature spaces I just
mentioned for concepts usually
focus on things or entities.
This one focuses on defining
relations in a similar way.
And of course, this has many
advantages over taxonomies as
well because taxonomies have
very few relation
concepts, kind of,
example of, things like that,
and taxonomies focus only on
categorizing entities.
Other knowledge organization
methods also describe
events, actions,
and contingencies
with relations
like agent, cause,
instrument,
manner, temporal order, etc.
And we've seen
that sets of well
defined conceptual relations
already exist.
They were developed
for artificial
intelligence the first
time around,
last century.
These are epistemological
assumptions,
assumptions about the form and
nature of knowledge,
in particular
about the role of
different notions of truth.
One very key
assumption is that
assertions are either entirely
true or entirely false.
There are no other options in
any circumstances.
So if item x is in category y
has to be entirely true or
entirely false,
then a statement like nursery
manager is in
category healthcare
jobs will force
us to incorrectly
classify professionals who
cultivate trees as
healthcare workers.
The most important
change here,
as advances in
machine learning
and deep learning have shown,
is to move from right wrong
present absent binary truth
values to
continuous confidence
scores that
represent likelihood
instead of absolute truth.
So if x if item
x is in category
y is no longer
entirely true or
entirely false,
then we can talk
about multiple
parents and use
case or context
dependent confidence
scores for
category assignment.
For example, in the context of
babies in hospitals,
nursery manager
is likely to be
a healthcare position.
In the context of
trees and shrubs,
nursery manager
is likely to be
an agricultural position.
We can make
category assignment
context dependent,
which is very,
very hard to do
with taxonomies.
All these building blocks will
allow us to
accumulate knowledge
and connect data by using
statements that
have explicitly
defined semantics,
what I call next generation
knowledge graphs.
Next generation
because today's
knowledge graphs do not always
use concepts with
explicit human
readable semantics.
And, of course,
there are many advantages over
taxonomies for these.
Some of them are things like
describing knowledge of events
and of relations
between statements,
not just entities.
And knowledge graphs aren't
restricted to one
entity type,
and they enable more kinds of
reliable inference.
Knowledge in this form will
provide a more
reliable foundation
for the next generation of
semantic technologies and AI.
So once again,
we've learned a few
more things. Now
we can see why
we need these
building blocks:
concept catalogs,
concept models,
explicit relation concepts,
more realistic epistemological
assumptions, and
knowledge graphs.
But how can we get there?
We need to shore
up our foundations
to reach these goals,
and I see significant
issues at
the base of our efforts.
We have to move
beyond believing
knowledge creation for AI in
the hands of naive, novice,
non practitioners.
We need systematic training
programs to create
essential talent.
We don't have them.
I've built taxonomy teams and
crowdsourcing programs.
I can tell you how very,
very hard it is.
We have to start
with fundamental
questions like, do we
need taxonomists?
What do they look like?
Where can we find them?
We need to explain this to
managers and
executives to fund
the work. We need to explain
this to HR to help us find and
cultivate talent.
Once we have the teams,
what's the best way
for them to work?
We simply don't know.
But we do know that we have to
move beyond simply
improvising.
We need industry
best practices
to follow.
We need industry
backed processes
to ensure reliable results,
and we don't have them.
Once we have a clear idea of
the best ways for
our teams to work,
how can we help them?
We don't want them to work
independently on
one item at a time
in random order,
slowly and manually,
like a sculptor crafting
a tiny statue.
We have to move
beyond crafting
to manufacturing knowledge.
We need tools to design and
validate knowledge.
We have to have
tools to ensure
reliable results at scale.
We don't have them,
and spreadsheets
just won't suffice.
To make semantic technologies
really thrive, we need all of
these things: better building
blocks and taxonomies,
more better trained
professionals,
explicit best practices,
and AI tools for design and
validation of knowledge,
not just for storage
and display.
Let's create together a better
foundation for
the next generation
of Symantec technologies and
connected data.
Thanks for your attention.